you are the heckler Wrangler so maybe we
start there in terms of the core
listeners all around the world comedians
and comedy nerds yo maybe break down how
to handle a heckler for us so the way
you handle a heckler is you make sure
the audience hates them more than you do
you give them enough rope to hang
themselves
you don't wrangle them they wrangle
themselves and the other thing is that
voice that tells you what to say and
what not to say shut it off and just go
with your instinct now the trick is you
have to not be a horrible human being
you know you have to not have it like
when Michael Richards said what he said
the tape doesn't show you how awful the
people were before he said what he said
but that doesn't matter because he said
something horrible because he thought
something horrible I would never even
thought what he said let alone set it
out loud in front of human beings so you
have to make sure you're a decent human
being also so you don't cross the line
and anger can come off a little yes one
of the things that I have to constantly
remind myself is if you can lean back
instead of leaning forward it'll come
off much better interests because that
person is trying to get to you mm-hmm
and so if you can just laugh at how
miserably they're failing then it'll be
much better than being like well I'll
tell you another thing your piece of
[__] you know you it's a little bit
better than so you almost let them like
hang themselves in a sense you do and
there's one actually I didn't get on
film where it's prot it might be the
meanest thing I've ever said to anybody
I was in Ann Arbor at the comedy
showcase and there was a very big bridal
party and there was one woman who would
not shut up she was making everything
about her and finally I was talking to
her and I found out she was the maid of
honor and first I did the whole like oh
great so you're gonna be talking at this
wedding be like you're making this about
you your friends special day and this is
still about you and finally when she
wouldn't shut up I said I really wish
you luck and catching the bouquet at the
wedding and she said oh I'm married and
I go yeah but your husband's gonna leave
you your
died alone so I wish you luck and I mean
I I told a woman her husband would leave
her and I and she died alone and the
audience applauded because they wanted
way worse for her than what I said they
were like oh he's going real easy on her
because she was just the worst right and
that's the that's really the trick it's
the gladiator you know you you win the
crowd you win the day hey hot brother
and sister if you love comedy as much as
we do here at hot breath click the
subscribe button to join the hot breath
averse and then watch more videos to get
even more comedy tips